[Music]
what strength exercises do you recommend
to keep aging bodies strong
okay um
well
one thing would be um
interval
training you know so doing small bouts
with regularity and you know so going in
and doing like uh
you could do
um
really any kind of like weightlifting
type thing but not doing long distance
aerobic stuff quite so much um
long-distance aerobic stuff ends up
being a bit more problematic for
hormones you know so going through and
doing like that like death march you
know and you're like exercising over and
over and over again you're doing you
know getting all your steps wrapped up
into one go
you come back and you feel depleted
you're like oh my god
that's going to be a little bit more
problematic for the body from a hormonal
perspective then doing like introducing
some weightlifting stuff in there if
you're gonna go for a run um do like i
said intervals so maybe do like a little
mini sprint or just like higher cadence
you know so maybe run 70
full out you know and then take a little
break do a little walk and then do you
know pick some some distances in between
two trees do a little run run to that
tree take a little break take a little
walk which once again that would make
sense because that replicates you know a
lot of what we would do from an
ancestral perspective right not to say
there's anything wrong with running
there's nothing wrong with running but
running is a very you know it's a
complex activity
you know and so i think that that's
the barrier to entry not the question
was about running but just comparing
doing like more higher intensity
interval type work compared to doing the
slow
endurance thing i think the barrier to
entry
it feels safer to do the slow gradual
thing okay i'm gonna work out so i'm
just to go do this for 45 minutes
it feels safer but in fact it actually
is much more dangerous
you know because you're gradually
building up stress on the joints from
moving through disadvantageous
or mechanically unsound positions over
and over and over and over again
you know so
for aging and longevity um high
intensity interval training and high
intensity is a relative word you know so
for high intensity for you
yeah and that could be as simple as
bodyweight exercises absolutely with
push-ups pull-ups squats those sorts of
things
and introducing weight training into
your into your um life yeah you know and
that could be
um a couple just a light barbell and
doing some lunges or doing some squats
having a coach you know that's what we
break down we break down in the book we
also have you know obviously i've tons
of videos and stuff online about how to
do this stuff effectively like form
really matters a lot
you know so
having a coach or someone spot you or
you know reading a book breaking down
like how exactly do we do this
but that weight bearing activity is
going to be helpful with sending the
signal through your bones and through
your connective tissue that it's time to
get more dense
you know so every time that we're
exposed to any type of mechanical
stimulus which ie us standing on the
floor right now there's pressure against
our feet if i pick something up off of
the ground i do a little deadlift or i
just pick a tennis ball up off of the
ground
i'm bearing load through these various
different joints in my body
that sends an electrical stimulus into
those places which causes these cells in
the body to either uh tear tissue down
or build tissue up around that area so
all day long by you exposing yourself to
pressure or to wait it's sending the
signal to those places those joints
those connective tissues those bones
saying okay build back stronger or if
you're just resting all the time those
connective tissues those bones those
joints they say okay we can kind of like
clear this out because we don't need to
be that strong
so the key to longevity is exposure you
need to keep exposing
that's really important
it makes a lot of sense especially
as we as we age we tend to lift fewer
things yes we do less movement in time
we become more and more
sedentary and it's not out of necessity
it's just out of the sort of cultural
demand on us to move becomes less and
less and the narrative that we tell
ourselves right you know like i work
with um clients like one-on-one on
occasion and when we're picking up
weights like like a trainer you know i
think like the polite thing to do is
like okay cool like i'll get the weights
i'll put them back and all that stuff
i'm like
okay that big heavyweight like you get
that one i'm gonna get these little guys
because you're here to do the work right
like you're you're paying me to
formulate this system ultimately for you
to effectively do work
right so while you're picking up that
weight that really heavy weight and
you're putting it back on the thing
you're paying attention okay how do i
get up and down off of the ground to
grab that weight how am i walking with
the weight how am i using my breath with
the weight
so starting to invite yourself so that
would be the first
answer is kind of a more of like a
sterile you know fitness type answer the
second answer is introducing
exposure to your life with regularity in
the form of don't be afraid of cold
temperatures don't be afraid of hot
temperatures don't be afraid of the sun
like get the heck out there
the moment that you take yourself out
of life your body and your mind it
starts to fold in
as long as you say no no no like i'm
gonna pick the weight up thank you very
much
you know like i know i'm a gal
you know and i it's a very very very
chivalrous of you to like pick up my
my my suitcase and put it in the thing
but i actually enjoy the sensation of
hinging my hips back and using my
intra-abdominal pressure for a second
and breathing in and
like that felt good so
that's a philosophical perspective on
fitness
changing the lens of the way that i
perceive exercise being the way that i
inhabit myself
all day long
and enjoying the process of doing work
as opposed to continually trying to push
work off to the side for somebody else
to do or some machine to do the
outsourcing of work is at the root of
the disease of disease of modern culture
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free